Unless you’ve been living under a rock for
the last eight years, you’ve probably noticed
a certain trend in superhero movies: the shared
universe.
While superhero films used to be treated as
independent series that would reset after
two or three movies, they now build on top
of each other to create an almost overwhelming
amount of shared continuity.
Case in point: the upcoming Captain America:
Civil War, which functions as a follow up
to Captain America: Winter Soldier, an action-packed
reunion of the Avengers: Age of Ultron cast
and an introduction to both Black Panther
as well as a new iteration of Spider Man!
But how long can this go on?
Hollywood’s obsession with fan approval
shows that one day a series that seems to
be riding strong (Amazing Spider Man, for
instance), can bottom out within 9 months
of the latest films release.
Steven Spielberg has even gone on record saying
the superhero film will soon go “the way
of the western” and fall out of popularity
in mainstream Hollywood.
Is the father of American Blockbuster Cinema
on to something?
Around 30 characters have already enjoyed
multiple appearances across the Marvel films
so far, and a library of characters in Marvel
Comics continuity that number in the thousands,
most of whom can appear and cross over between
a number of films and TV series.
With a potentially infinite number of combinations,
will this cinematic universe collapse under
its own weight?
Or will the Marvel Cinematic Universe go on
FOREVER?
The History: How Marvel Became a Movie Studio
It may be inconceivable now, but there was
a time when Marvel wasn’t a huge player
in blockbuster filmmaking.
It used to be just a comics publisher that
would license its intellectual property to
various movie studios.
The first movie based on a marvel comic property
was the Captain America serial, released in
1944, back when Marvel Comics was known as
Timely Comics.
Instead of Steve Rogers, Captain America’s
alter ego was District Attorney Grant Gardner,
played by Dick Purcell, who actually died
a few weeks after filming was completed.
Changes like these, as well as the omission
of Captain America’s iconic shield, made
the finished film extremely unpopular with
creators and fans of the character.
The next film adaptation of a Marvel property
was 42 years later, a co-production between
Universal Studios and LucasFilm.
Howard the Duck was released in 1986 to critical
scorn and financial ruin, tanking the careers
of most of its cast, and forcing George Lucas
to sell the animation branch of LucasFilm
in order to recoup his own personal losses.
Far from being the box office gold they are
now, Marvel licensed a couple direct-to-DVD
releases as well as a still unreleased Fantastic
Four movie before their first major blockbusters
hit the screens with Blade and X-Men over
a decade later.
The Kevin Feige Years
As the success of the X-Men and Spider Man
movies began to gain traction for the superhero
movie genre, the newly incorporated Marvel
Studios began re-acquiring movie rights to
characters it had sold off to other studios
around 2004, with the intent to develop in-house
feature films.
By 2007, the studio had the film rights to
Iron Man, Ant-Man, and The Incredible Hulk.
They hired producer Kevin Feige to oversee
the project as Iron Man began production in
2007.
The massive success of Iron Man lead to a
snowball effect that took the blockbuster
world by storm, but Feige and Marvel Studios
were only getting started.
Within 4 years, the MCU had not only created
fresh new adaptations of Thor and Captain
America, it saw the first major crossover
film, The Avengers, become the third highest
grossing film of all time.
The infrastructure of the MCU, overseen and
produced by Kevin Feige, has held so far.
What possibly could stop them?
Possible Obstacle #1: Box Office Failure?
One major franchise killer in Hollywood is
the prospect of financial ruin.
The paranoia surrounding box office numbers
is one massive reason for Hollywood Studios
to rely on surefire hits – like popular
comic books, for instance.
But what financial disaster could possibly
derail Marvel?
As of 2010, Marvel is owned by Disney, one
of the few companies with carte blanche to
do whatever it wants with intellectual property
it owns.
Considering they now own Lucasfilm’s properties
as well, it would take a financial storm of
biblical proportions to get Disney to lose
enough money to consider Marvel a liability.
And considering the closest thing the Marvel
Cinematic Universe has to a box office Failure
is 2008’s The Incredible Hulk, which still
made its budget back with over 250 million
worldwide, it does not seem the MCU is in
any real financial danger – in the foreseeable
future.
Possible Obstacle # 2: Critical Disaster?
But will the movies be able to sustain their
own quality standard?
Franchises like Transformers, which routinely
make massive amounts of money despite critical
derision are common, but part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe’s appeal is that the
films themselves are generally held to a higher
standard than your average blockbuster.
Can the studio sustain the same level of critical
favour as their movies get more complex and
potentially convoluted?
This possibility is inherently more difficult
to predict, because there are two kinds of
backlash that could force Marvel to change
course: fan backlash and critical backlash.
Once again, we find ourselves looking at the
biggest critical failure of the MCU: The Incredible
Hulk.
The Incredible Hulk received mixed response
from fans and critics alike, much like its
2003 predecessor, and there hasn’t been
a solo Hulk movie since.
Edward Norton was replaced by Mark Ruffalo
for The Avengers, and the greater cinematic
universe continued unimpeded.
That is the Ace in the Hole for Marvel – The
MCU serves as a system of checks and balances
in case any particular series underperforms
or is critically panned.
Soft reboots are commonplace, as evidenced
by Tom Holland’s appearance as a new Spider-Man
in Captain America: Civil War.
And even if films are released to critical
indifference, like the two Thor films, their
characters’ relation to The Avengers keeps
them afloat.
The Marvel Strategy: Filmmakers
How does one guarantee consistent quality?
Marvel Studios’ ongoing plan follows the
pattern that made both X-Men and Spider Man
a success in the early 2000s: Find up and
coming directors with interesting voices,
and tap their talent for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe.
Who would have thought the director of Elf,
Jon Favreau, would make a great Iron Man movie?
From Kenneth Branagh to James Gunn, Feige
and the heads of Marvel are exceedingly clever
at tapping talent for their projects - so
that their movies stay relevant to current
cinema.
The hiring department at Marvel remains the
best at poaching rising talent from smaller
or more obscure ends of the movie industry.
Just recently, they signed acclaimed Creed
and Fruitvale Station director Ryan Coogler
and What We Do in the Shadows director Taika
Waititi for Black Panther and Thor: Ragnarok
respectively.
And with their new Spider Man film, it seems
Marvel is exceptionally clever at catering
to what their audiences want on both the filmmaking
side as well as the content side.
Obstacle #3: Introducing Audiences to New
Characters
Probably the biggest doubt everyone ever had
about the Marvel experiment was how they would
get a mainstream movie-going public invested
in shared universe storytelling in the same
way fans of their comics are.
They proved they could make stand alone stories
about their heroes engaging, but bringing
that full universes together seemed like a
different challenge entirely.
Keeping diverse mythologies and scores of
characters straight is something that people
can barely manage for one franchise, how could
they think this would work for multiple intersecting
series?
Though it was clear by The Avengers that the
MCU was a box office success, it was in Guardians
of the Galaxy that Marvel proved their brand
alone is worth more than the individual comics
they adapt.
Guardians of the Galaxy took a goofy space
opera, that even some Marvel fans didn’t
know well, starring a talking tree and racoon,
and made it a success on par with their other
films.
And Marvel’s smaller screen ventures as
well – such as Jessica Jones and the upcoming
Luke Cage – prove the studio can draw attention
to even the most obscure property with the
right creative staff.
All they have to do is worry about sharing
that continuity with the Avengers.
Obstacle #4: Too Many Characters
The most present threat to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe seems is likely one that comic book
movie fans would have never imagined.
Managing a whole Universe is a tricky thing,
and while Marvel has so far been successful
at their shared universe experiments, when
will the world they’ve created simply become
too big to sustain?
Avengers: Age of Ultron garnered criticism
for feeling trimmed down, and now Avengers:
Infinity War is set to be a saga-spanning
epic with a budget reportedly around 1 Billion
dollars between two films and a cast overstuffed
with Marvel regulars.
As viewers of Batman V. Superman: Dawn of
Justice can attest, trying to cram too many
characters, events, and effects into your
movie can result in a film that is more overblown
than necessary, and deters new viewers.
In a movie series that has weathered metaphors
for Terrorism as well as fantasy space magic,
is there any going back once they threaten
to blow up the known universe?
There is no ready answer for this particular
question, but the numerous franchise obligations
of the series has previously proved overwhelming
for directors working under Marvel’s umbrella.
See for instance, any interview Joss Whedon
attended during the press tour for Age of
Ultron.
Obstacle #5: Audience Fatigue
The biggest and most dangerous obstacle Marvel
may face is their own success.
With 2-3 films a year, Marvel Studios is the
largest producer of superhero films, and it
is matched by their competitors in DC and
Fox, producing Justice League and X-Men sequels
to fight for their piece of the superhero
pie, making for an average 5 – 7 superhero
films a year for the foreseeable future.
This is what Spielberg was referencing when
comparing the superhero film genre to the
western in old Hollywood.
Back when western TV shows and movies were
all the rage, the genre suffered from oversaturation,
and eventually fell out of fashion.
But is it an accurate comparison to draw parallels
between the two genres?
A large influence in the western falling out
of favour was growing cynicism toward the
myth of the west and American exceptionalism
post-World War II.
And, let’s face it: The western is not nearly
as flexible as the superhero film, which in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe encompasses
heist movies (Ant Man), espionage thrillers
(Captain America: Winter Soldier) and space
operas (Guardians of the Galaxy), among other
subgenres.
Still, shared universe fatigue is a reality
that modern Hollywood will have to face.
Now that Star Wars is branching out into standalone
films and DC is trying their best to catch
up with the MCU, the blockbuster market is
leaning toward shared universes more and more.
Will the bubble burst on multiverses - and
audiences will, instead, start craving satisfying
standalone experiences?
The MCU is built to sustain both smaller individual
films and galaxy spanning epics, but dwindling
audience interest may make billion dollar
ventures like Avengers: Infinity War a bigger
risk than might seem apparent right now.
With a plan going through 2028, it’s clear
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is dedicated
to keeping its own course.
If it ends, it is going to be on the terms
of Kevin Feige and Marvel Studios, not due
to external forces such as the performance
of the inevitable Justice League movies or
Avengers: Infinity War.
Will audiences lose interest and prove Spielberg
right, or is this money making machine never
stopping?
So what do you think?
Are you suffering from superhero fatigue or
have you already marked every Marvel opening
night in your calendar?
Remember to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this.
Hey Screen Rant viewers!
We want to tell you about another great YouTube
channel you should subscribe to called Wisecrack.
Click HERE to be taken to their channel page,
where you'll find smart and funny explorations
of movies, TV shows, video games, and more.
Wisecrack dives into the deeper meaning of
stuff like The Matrix, Guardians of the Galaxy,
Rick & Morty, The Dark Knight, and Fight Club
– and they’ve got new videos around the
corner for X-Men: First Class, The Social
Network, Game of Thrones, and more.
So click HERE to visit their channel page
and subscribe.
Tell them Screen Rant sent you!"